HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME OUT THERE
- HAPPY NEW YEAR WELCOME TO THE
FIRST MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE MEETING-
AROUND START ON TIME- SO THAT WE
CAN WE CAN START TO YOUR OFFER
RIGHT- FIRSTLY YOU KNOW. THEY
WANT ME TOPOUND THE GAVEL BUT
BEFORE I DO THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR NEWEST MEMBERS. OF
OUR- COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIA. IS MERELY SERVE A MEAL
BONTA. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
THINK BRIAN. TO BUFFY WELCOME-
WE DON'T NORMALLY DO THIS BUT-
WE NEVER DONE GONNA GET THIS
MANY PEOPLE COMING UP IF YOU
WANTED WILL SAVE. COUPLE WORKING
FOR BEGIN- I WOULD. LOTUS HAVE
YOU SEE A COUPLE WORKED.
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE THANK YOU
MESSAGES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BROTHER TO. PRESHEAF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A PART OF ONE
OF THE STRONGEST A COMMITTEES IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND ALL THAT WE
CAN DO TOGETHER. THANK YOU-
SUBJECT YES. YES L'ACCORD LIKE
TO ALSO WELCOME OUR NEW MEMBERS
I'VE BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE NINE
YEARS I THINK IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENT
HIVE HAVE. WE KILL A LOT OF HAVE
BEEN HELD. AND WE PASS A GREAT
ONES. PARTICULARLY I THINK THE
USE OF FORCE. OUR THAT TO USE OF
FORCE BILL THAT WE PASSED A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. YOU ARE VERY
LUCKY TO BE ON THIS AND WE'RE
LUCKY TO HAVE YOU BECAUSE I
KNOW. YOU'RE YOU'RE ALIGNED WITH
THE CHAIR AND MYSELF IN. MAKING
GREAT PROGRESS WE'VE BEEN. ALL
RIGHTY SO I'M GOING TO. THE
GAVEL OUT SUCH PROBABLY SHOULD
WORK YOU EARLIER- SO QUICKLY
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY MEETING
IS NOW IN ORDER WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND SECRETARY CALLED. CALDERON
JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY. BONTA
BRIAN COURT PRESENTS SANTIAGO
THEY ARE TO HERE. OKAY SO- WE
HAVE SOME- PUBLIC SAFETY THE
THINGS YOU NEED TO READ- IN
ORDER THAT WE CAN BEGIN THE
MEETING AND MAKE SURE THAT-
OBVIOUSLY THAT EVERYONE WILL BE
SAFE. AND THAT WE CAN CONDUCT
THESE MEETINGS AND THEN IN THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE WAY- OBVIOUSLY
WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE HEARING- BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AT- H. T. T.
P. S. DOT- OKAY WITH A BACKSET
MEASURES A P. S. F. DOT ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT GOV- BACKSLASH PLEASE
NOTE THAT. ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEES
CONSIDER PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED ALL ARE ENCOURAGED TO
WATCH THE HEARING FROM ITS LIVE
STREAM ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
WEBSITE- W. W. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOV GOP SLASH TODAY.
TODAY'S EVENTS. THE CAPITAL WILL
BE OPEN FOR ATTENDANCE FOR THIS
HEARING. ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDING A HEARING IN
THE CAPITOL WHERE WHERE WILL
NEED TO WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
WHILE IN THE BUILDING. THE
REASON IS STRONGLY ENCOURAGED TO
PARTICIPATE VIA WEB PORTAL OR
PHONE USING THE NUMBER PROVIDED
ON THE SCREEN. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR UPDATES.
IT IS THE CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF
THIS COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY FIVE MINUTES PER SIDE
ON EACH BILL I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ JUST CAME AND
SO I REPEAT IT IS CUSTOM. AND
PRACTICE OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
ALLOW TESTIMONY FIVE MINUTES PER
SIDE ON EACH BILL. WE AFTER ALL
OF THE PARTICIPANTS STATE YOUR
NAME. ORGANIZATION AND STANCE
WITH THAT. BUT OUR HOUSEKEEPING
WILL GO TO OUR CONSENT CALENDAR-
WE HAVE. NUMBER ONE IS AB
FORTINO SIX I BELIEVE THAT MR
LACKEY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
POLICIES CARRYING OF EQUIPMENT
AND ITEM NUMBER TWO AB FOUR
EIGHT FIVE AND WHEN HE CRIES
REPORTING THAT IS ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR TO HAVE A MOTION TO
APPROVE. SECOND THE MOTION TO
APPROVE AND SECOND YOU CAN CALL
THE ROLL. JONES SAWYER HI THERE
HI LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA HI
BONTA HI BRIAN HI RYAN HI CORK.
I WORK AT A SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO
HI THEY ARE TOO HIGH THEY ARE
TOO HIGH. IT DID WE HAVE A THAT
THAT MOTION PASSES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROVED- WE HAVE
ONE MAJOR LEFT A. B. TWO TWO
EIGHT RODRIGUEZ MISTER RODRIGUEZ
WELCOME TO OUR FIRST MEETING.
OUR FIRST WITNESS OUR FIRST
TESTIMONY FIRST FIRST FIRST. I
TELL YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO
ALABAMA LAST NIGHT OF TO CHANGE
IT IS. THE LITTLE BORN AT FIRST
BUT- FACT. THANK YOU WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A. B. TWO
TWO EIGHT WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INSPECTOR FARM DEALERS AT LEAST
EVERY THREE YEARS TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH FARM LAW CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE INSPECTOR FIRE ARMS
DEALERS TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH FIRE ARMS LAW BUT THERE IS
NO REQUIREMENT TO INSPECT. ON A
REGULAR BASIS AT ALL. FARM
DEALERS HAVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
UPHOLD FAR ARM LAWS. TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES FROM INDIVIDUALS
PROHIBITED BY LAW FROM OWNING
THE POSSESSION OF FIREARMS ARE
STRICTLY US RIVALS. THANK YOU
BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES.
OR DID ANYONE. OKAY SO MANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. K. C. NINE
HEARING ON I GUESS ARE GOING TO
SCREEN THIS TIME OR- ANY OF THAT
ON THE PHONE ARE WE DOING THAT
AT ALL. MISTER AT AND T. DO YOU
HAVE ANYONE ONLINE OR ON THE
PHONE. YES TO CHAIR WILL YOU MAY
BURKE THIS IS FOR IN SUPPORT OF
A AB TWO TWO EIGHT RODRIGUEZ
THEY WE WERE NOT READY FOR
TESTING. THURMOND WHO WOULD NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR STANCE.
BLAZON GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO
SPUR US SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IS
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. DO CHAIR NO
ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK OKAY IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE IN THE BUILDING IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEN NONE
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
ANYONE WITH ANY QUESTIONS
CONCERNS- WELL IT IS THERE NO
POSITIO I'M SORRY THIS NEW YEAR
AGO TO CATCH UP. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO IT AB TWO TWO
EIGHT. SEEING NONE IN THE ROOM-
WILL AGAIN DO THE SAME WITH THE
OPPOSITION GIVEN THEM MISTER
EIGHTY EIGHTY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
TWO EIGHT RODRIGUEZ. NO ONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR KNOWN AS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THERE'S NO
ONE ON THE LINE. BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE AND I BELIEVE MR
LACKEY HAS A STATEMENT OR
QUESTION YEAH ORANGE MORE
QUESTION IS ARE. A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ANYWHERE AVAILABLE
MAYBE IN THE ROOM I JUST I SEE
THERE'S NO ONE ONLINE. THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE. OKAY THE REASON WHY
I ASK THAT IS OUR OUR STAFF AND
MYSELF HAVE QUESTIONS ON HOW
THIS WOULD IMPACT THE OPERATIONS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
BUT APPARENTLY WE CAN'T GET AN
ANSWER TO THAT BUT THAT'S
IMPORTANT- I'M- I'M CERTAIN. AND
BECAUSE I KNOW- BURKE WILL WEEK
CERVETERI JOURNAL OF BONTA DEAD
IF THE DEPARTMENT HAD ANY
PROBLEM FOR QUANTITY WOULD HAVE
NOTIFIED THIS COMMITTEE BUT
NOTIFIED THE AUTHOR. AND SOME OF
US HAVE A PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH YOU TO AND YOU KNOW SO I'M
PRETTY SURE WE HAVE GOTTEN SOME
HIT. BUT WHAT IF THERE WAS A
PROBLEM SO I WOULD WE'VE BEEN
ASKING THIS QUESTION FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING WE- WHAT. WHAT'S
THE CURRENT PROBLEM WHERE. IS
WHAT WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT. WHAT
THEY'RE DOING NOW IF ANYTHING
ALL YOU JUST WANT TO KNOW.
PROCESS YES BY. HELLO MISTER
CLARK. I'M WILLING TO BET THAT.
I'M GOING TO BE VOTING FOR YOUR
BAIL- I'M WILLING TO BET THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CAPABILITY AT
THIS TIME TO DO IT BECAUSE
YOU'RE SO FAR BEHIND. WHAT OTHER
ISSUES SUCH AS GETTING PEOPLE
WHO HAVE GUNS THAT ARE ILLEGAL.
AND GETTING TO THEM AND PRESENT
AND- PUTTING THOSE GUNS IN THEIR
POSSESSION. SO IF I WERE YOU MR
AUTHOR- I WOULD WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT- TO SEE HOW YOU VIEW
YOUR BILL CAN BE MODIFIED OR
PERHAPS THERE'S A BUDGET ASK YOU-COULD HAVE. THOUGHT BECAUSE THIS
IS JYJ THERE ARE MORE GUN STORES
THAN MCDONALD'S- SO THIS IS A
HUGE COMMITMENT OF TIME AND
MONEY. AND OF- I THINK YOU'VE
GOT A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF US
WE'RE ONLY GOING TO VOTE ON THE
POLICY TODAY. BUT THE IMPACT ON
THAT DEPARTMENT WILL BE GREAT.
NOT A GOOD POINT I WOULD ALSO
JUST LET YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO
MEMBERS OF SUPP FIVE CITY
LAUNCHED COMMITTEE. THAT COULD
BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL AND- MAKING
SURE THAT THIS IS BUDGETED
APPROPRIATELY WE HAVEN'T HAD OUR
FIRST MEETING YET BUT- YOU COULD
START LOBBYIST RIGHT NOW AND
THEN. AND HOPEFULLY YOU GET TO
VOTED IN TICKET TO REQUIRE THREE
SO- I BELIEVE THAT'S IMPORTANT
IS A POLICY COMMITTEE- BUT- AS
MR LACKEY MR CORKER'S POINTED
OUT WHAT WE NEED TO BE VERY
SENSITIVE TO RESOURCES MONEY AND
THE ABILITY TO GET THE START.
APPLICATION BASICALLY. WHAT
THANK VERY MUCH I OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS THE FIRST HEARING OF THIS
BILL AND I'M SURE WITHIN TIME
THINGS WILL PROBABLY BE MODIFIED
TO CHANGE IT TO MAKE IT MORE
FEASIBLE. AND WORK WITH A
PARTNER JUSTICE TO SEE HOW WE
CAN GET OTHER SUPPORT. AND
REALLY JUST ADDRESSED THIS ISSUE
RIGHT HOW WE GET THOSE FOLKS
LICENSE AT LEAST. EVERY THREE
YEARS OF NOT WE CAN WORK ON
SOMETHING ELSE BUT THE FACT THAT
THERE IS NOTHING IN STATUTE THAT
SAYS. THEY ARE TO BE EXPECTED IS
A PROBLEM SO WE NEED TO SEE HOW
WE COULD NOT CORRECT THAT ISSUE
MOVING FORWARD. OKAY SO WITHOUT
RESPECT US ROAD THANK YOU SHARES
RECOMMENDED NINE I DID DECIDE TO
WE NEED TO DO- NOT CERTAIN JUST
BECAUSE EVERY. WEEK I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE THE LUXURY OF. THE
EXCUSE THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY. AS THE- HAS POINTED OUT
YESTERDAY. SO WITH THAT CALL THE
ROLL. AB T. TWO EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY HI
BONTA. BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I
WORK I WORK HI SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I SAY ARTIFACT THEY ARE
TOO HIGH. THE MEASURE PASSAGE
THANK YOU AND THEN WILL TAKE UP
OUR ONLY OTHER IS A TAKE UP VOTE
ONLY OUR LAST ITEM TODAY IS A.
B. TWO SIX SIX COOPER THIS
MEASURE WAS GRANTED
RECONSIDERATION IS SPRING AND IS
UP FOR VOTE ONLY. KNOW
PRESENTATION IS REQUIRED AND THE
BILL HAS NOT BEEN AMENDED- HELLO
ON AB TWO SIX SIX BY SOME MEMBER
COOPER THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER NO JONES SAWYER
NILE LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA.
BONTA NEL BRIAN NO BRIAN NO CORK
. NOW SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO KNOWS
R. TWO SEE OUR T<c.cyan>. YEAH THAT</c>
MEASURE FAILS- AND SO THIS
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING ON TIME AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIX THIS CLOCK
IS STOPPED AT NINE O'CLOCK SO.
HOPEFULLY IT'S NOT. WHEN THE
WHENEVER THE STOCK WHEN MR
LACKEY WALKED IN. MISTER CHAIR I
THINK YOU NEED TO ADD ON FOR
THE- CONSENT CALENDAR- YES YES
YOU GET. OKAY A LOT QUICKER
CONSENT CALENDAR. WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO WE'RE DOING THAT IN
FACT OKAY VETERANS THANK YOU.
GOOD BUSINESS ON THE DAILY DATA
. OKAY ALSO TO. OKAY THANK YOU
SO I'LL SAY IT AGAIN THIS
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU. YEAH
COMMITTEE CHAIR.